problema número 218 cuando los
siguientes no puede ser la mediana de
los tres enteros positivos x y z veamos
cada uno x este sí podría ser la mediana
si estos números estuvieran ordenados
como x z o z x y la x estaría en medio
si están ordenados estos números
recordemos que la mediana es el número
del mes veamos la siguiente opción b z
pues también también podría ser la
mediana si estuvieran ordenados estos
números como x z
o como jay-z x de manera que z quede a
la mitad sea la mediana eso sí se podría
cumplir ahora qué pasa con x + zeta
esto puede ser la mediana bueno si
suponemos que la mediana es x maceta
entonces mi x ni z podrían ser la medida
tendría que hacer por fuerza g y el
orden quedaría como x
o z y equis pero la suma x zeta no puede
ser menor que zeta o que x ya que estoy
usando estos dos números para obtener
esta suma de este resultado por lo que
esta opción no puede ser una mediana es
mi opción c veamos el siguiente problema
problema número 219 cuál es el dígito
número 25 a la derecha del punto decimal
de la fracción 6 entre 11 bueno cuando
les pidan algo ridículo busquen algún
patrón que nos ayude a encontrar la
respuesta en este caso cuál es el dígito
número 25 vamos a hacer la división
comencemos a hacerla aquí es 6 entre 11
voy a poner aquí unos ceros después del
punto decimal porque los voy a necesitar
tuvo el punto decimal y comienzo a hacer
la división 5 por 11 55 60 55 quedan 5
bajó el 0 4 por 11 es 44 hago la resta
me queda aquí 6 bajo otro 0 y multiplicó
por 5 5 por 11 55 y aquí estoy empezando
a ver un patrón están quedándome 60 o 40
de recibo por lo que este patrón 5 454
se va a repetir hasta el infinito
entonces ya veo que este número va a ser
punto 5 454 5 454 etcétera y ahora me
queda ver cuál de estos números va a
coincidir en el lugar número 25 veamos
en el lugar 123 en estos lugares los
nones me está quedando el 5 y en los
padres me va a quedar 4 25 es un número
impar por lo que me va a quedar un 5 en
el lugar 25 y esta es mi opción c
siguiente problema problema número 220 a
juani amaría les pagaron de manera
individual x pesos por adelantado para
hacer un trabajo juntos juan trabajo 10
horas y maria dos horas menos que juan
ella dio 10 pesos de su sueldo para que
ambos recibirán el mismo pago por ahora
cuál fue la cantidad de pesos en
términos de que se le pagó a juan por
adelantado a no tenemos los datos juan
trabajó 10 horas y estas 10 horas
recibió x pesos maria trabajo 10 horas
menos 2 trabajo ocho horas y recibió x
pesos pero como maria nadie pesos de su
pago a juan para que ambos reciban el
mismo pago por hora entonces juan recibe
x + y media recibe x menos podemos
expresar esto como el sueldo de maria x
x - es igual a punto 8 que es el rango
de horas con respecto a las que trabajo
juan y lo que trabajo juanes x más lo de
sueldo que recibe pues juan es esto por
lo que maría recibe ocho décimos del
dinero de juego vamos a ver
- es igual a factor izando esto nos
queda 0.8 x mas 0.8 y restamos punto 8x
de ambos lados me va a quedar punto 2x
menos igual a punto 8 y sumo en ambos
lados me va a quedar punto 2x igual a
1.8 1.8 de estos 8 es que raros a iván y
ahora multiplicamos ambos lados por 5
para tener aquí un 13 multiplico esto
por 5 y esto por 5 me queda x igual a
1.8 por 5 es igual a 9 y esto es en
términos de hielo que se le pagó a juan
y es mi opción e iconos o terminamos los
problemas de este vídeo